early. He was
[Silence]
For
stash head
Continuing in real
the last narration
of the chapter regarding repentance
narration number 24
on the authority of
who narrates that the messenger of Allah
said
Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala will smile smile
at two men, one of which will have
killed the other, yet both will enter
paradise.
Then he goes on to explain how this
happens. He says
the first is fighting for the sake of
Allah and is martyed
and then Allah
forgives, accepts the repentance of the
killer
who then enters into Islam and then is
subsequently martyed himself.
This narration was collected by both
bkari and Muslim
with the majority of the scholars of
hadith. When they say agreed upon,
what's meant is that it was both
collected by Bkari and Muslim. It was
collected by both Bkari and Muslim in
their authentic compilations.
So,
Bkari has many books. Muslim has many
books. If Muslim reports a narration
or Al Bkari reports that same narration
in other
than their authentic compilations, it's
not agreed upon. It's only agreed upon
when it's both collected by Bkari and
Muslim. Both narrations are in Bkari and
Muslim with chains of narration.
So
here we have a narration on the
authority of Abi
in which
Noah
we at first glance can't really see the
reason why he placed this narration in
this chapter. It's not readily apparent
as to why it is he mentions this
narration in this chapter.
Except for the statement of the prophet
Sam
meaning that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
forgives and accepts the repentance of
the killer.
However, when we look at the spirit of
the narration,
what do we understand from the spirit of
the narration?
The spirit of the narration tells us
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
may have things in store for someone
who in the moment would seem to be
hellbound.
Would seem to be hellbound.
There are few sins more great than
killing a Muslim.
There are few sins more great than being
in an army that kills Muslims, fighting
against the Muslims, fighting against
Islam. This is a terrible situation for
a person to be in. One of the worst
situations to find oneself in any
situation on this earth.
However, in spite of the circumstances,
this man just killed a Muslim in battle.
Not because he's angry, not because of
just any reason. He killed him because
this person was fighting for Islam and
he is fighting against Islam actively.
And so
this man's blood is now the blood of a
martyr and his killer has committed one
of the greatest sins possible for a
human being to commit.
However, in spite of these
circumstances,
there's still hope
for this person.
Yes, he just killed a Muslim in battle
actively fighting against Islam.
This is a terrible situation, but
there's still hope for this person.
As long as a person as we read in the
earlier narrations in the chapter
that Allah accepts the repentance of a
servant of a slave
as long as he is not in his death rattle
in the thro thrashes of death
and so as long as there is breath in a
person's breast
As long as they have not reached that
that time just before the soul is is
taken from the body, there's still hope.
No matter how bleak the situation seems
and hopeless. What is the Quran? What is
it? It's a book of hope. That's why
Allah calls it and refers to it as
light.
And that light pierced the darkness that
humanity was in that seemed to be
unfixable.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam himself
said
[Silence]
Sai wasallam. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said that before he sent the
prophet Muhammad
he looked upon the people of earth
and he hated them all
Arab and non-Arab alike.
What does that mean? Hated them all.
Meaning
that they were upon misguidance.
They were in
a society
that they have committed crime and they
have committed atrocities and and
heinous acts and indecency so much that
it became part of their pride and
culture.
When we look at the ways of the people
of Jahyah, they were worshiping idols.
They were making around the Kaa, the
house of Allah in the nude,
claiming that this is something Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has told them to do.
How could it get worse than that?
Worshiping everything except for Allah.
fearing magicians and soothsayers,
believing in anyone who comes to pull
their ear.
they were in a in a in a time when
part of their culture
was the thought the thinking was that
look if a man's father passes away who
is more rightful to his wives his son.
even if it's his own mother.
When men were bedding with each other,
when animals were being consummated
with,
it was a time of incredible darkness.
However, in spite of that darkness,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent the
Quran.
And in 23 short years, look what
humanity became.
And so here we have a very bleak
situation.
We have a man who has has been sent to
paradise. He is martyed. And then we
have his killer who has seemingly
already earned his definite ticket to
the hellfire. However, Allah has a plan
for this man. Why does Allah forgive
some and not others? Oh, Adam, this is
something that goes back to Allah's
wisdom.
This is something that goes back to
Allah's wisdom. Here we have Abu Talib.
He helps the Muslim.
He protects the prophet Sam. Wasam. He
starves alongside the Muslim for three
years
and he goes to hell.
Then we have a man
on the converse who kills a Muslim in
battle and he goes to paradise.
This is what this goes back to the
wisdom of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So the point here is that Allah
subhanahu waala will smile upon two men
on the day of judgment. One of which has
killed the other, both of which will
enter paradise.
And so what is meant here by smile
is one of those words that has
changed its meaning in our tongue in
Arabic over the years. When we say in
modern Arabic,
what does it mean? It usually means
laughter.
And when we say smile, we'd say,
right? However, in the Arabic language,
the ancient Arabic language, a bahik is
smiling to where the teeth will show
or smiling wide. A a smile. This is what
a smile is. This is what is.
Now, we understand
what
is and what it means in the Arabic
language.
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said it
Allah will smile upon two men.
However, how will Allah smile? This is
the domain of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And it is not permissible even for a
Muslim who exalts Allah as he is due to
ask how does Allah do anything of his
names and attributes because it's
inconceivable to the human being
Allah rose above the throne. He said it
in his book in eight different places.
What does that mean? How did he rise
above the throne? This is inconceivable.
And we will end with a statement from
Malik.
A man came to him and said,
for
[Silence]
A man came to him and asked
Alman rose above the throne.
How did he rise above the throne?
Notice the the question here. He rose
above the throne. How?
How?
This articulates an arrogance from the
human being who asks such a question.
The mere idea that I could know with my
little brain how Allah, the creator of
the heavens and the earth does what he
does. So, I im Malik responded and said,
"Rising above is known." meaning in the
Arabic language. It's understood.
How is inconceivable to the human being
and belief in it is obligatory because
it's in the Quran and asking about it is
an innovation. Why is it an innovation?
because the companions all
unanimously
agreed on not asking this question. You
could take any attribute or action of
Allah that's mentioned in the Quran and
Sunnah and place it in this response
and
Foreham.
[Silence]
Alhamdulill.